What are you talking about? I literally told you from the get
when this whole thing started that I would never leave them alone.
>> I want to know that. >> Stop. Stop yelling.
>> The second I don't stop talking about Happened to coincide
when I took into my service some fine Canadian lawyers. >> He
doesn't want to say it so bad. >> I'm so sorry, Ethan.
>> Hey, this guy is not okay. This guy is actually absolutely
not okay whatsoever.
Are we going to get into the Ethan stuff? So, Ethan had a bunch
of drama early earlier this week, okay? He made these comments
about a woman being a prostitute at this poker tournament. Okay,
so the same poker tournament where he went in and he took the
screenshot of
>> Congratulations to the Eklers, expecting baby number
one. >> Everything's neutral. Got both names So, hopefully
we find out. >> Congratulations to the Eklers, expecting
baby number one. >> Everything's neutral. >> Got
both names ready.
>> Okay, so the same poker tournament where he went in,
took the screenshot of Anisa. He was commenting on this woman,
okay? Let's see what Ethan Klein had to >> I'm all I I
don't want to be rude, but I'm pretty sure she's a prostitute.
And I really don't want to say that. >> No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. >> That's not all right. >> I
don't want to be rude, but I'm pretty sure she's a prostitute.
>> No, I'm serious. >> Cool. Cool. Cool.
>> No, I'm serious. No, I'm serious. No, I'm serious. >> She
was playing in the She was playing at CPT.
>> I don't think she was. >> No, she was, bro. She
was. She was. >> You're very wrong. >> Oh, she's
>> Yeah, don't let's say that. >> there. Well, okay.
I'm I apologize then. That was rude. >> That's not all
right. >> Well, I didn't say it to her. Luckily, she didn't
hear me. >> Bro, you're on a broadcast.
Dog, you're on a broadcast.
She does have a huge Instagram. Like, I think her Instagram
millions of followers?
Yeah, 3.2 million followers on
Actress of some kind in a prime series apparently. Clearly somebody
who probably shouldn't be getting called a prostitute, right?
So apparently Ethan Klein interviewed her before this as
>> gay people in Russia, is that true?
>> Uh gay people are everywhere. >> They're everywhere.
All right. Okay. I want to say this for Galia. >> Oh, you
can tell that she gets like Russophobia all over the place, right?
You can tell that the fact that she has a Russian accent, she
has to deal with this in North America all the time. People just
hating her because of her >> Now, we're going to find Putin.
What the We're going to drone him. Does she need
>> The drones will find Putin. >> Privet. Kak dela?
>> Yes. What did that mean? That just means >> means
like he's hot.
>> He's rich, too. I don't know if you know that. Oh, come
on. >> It's not about money. >> Yeah, I'm rich, too.
>> It's not about money. Trust me. This guy This guy's
got
>> But he's grandma mom >> Is that right? Where And
where do you want you to do it? To have that I appreciate that,
but money doesn't make >> I have a restaurant in Los Angeles.
I'm a founder of Miss Russia. I have a lot of things. >> You're
founder of Miss Russia. Are you an oligarch?
>> Are you like a oligarch?
>> Dude, I This is like I understand that people hate Russia
a lot, okay? I get But like this is You have to understand this
is like xenophobia, right? This is like some form of Like the
values he claims to have is like a clear example of not having
those values. Oh, you have this label? Well, are you like all
of the things I associate with this label? Are you literally
all
of the things I associate with this It's like
Yeah, that's the thing that you're like not supposed to do. When
you see an individual, you're not supposed to immediately apply
all the things from that label to that individual. That's like
a form of bigotry.
It's It's like he doesn't even understand
remotely why you shouldn't be a bigot. He just knows what's what
words not to use or what things not to say to not seem like a
bigot. But when he's outside of where he's already learned, he's
just totally fine applying bigotry to people. Anyway, I do believe
he apologizes on his Instagram, says that was out of line for
me. But now he is going to talk about drama that happened. So,
calling this woman a prostitute, and that's where he took the
Anissa screenshot from the snark subreddit, okay? >> We're
going to cover the Anissa stuff now. Let's go. >> with
our good friends
uh items and Anissa.
Uh which very funny um coincidental thing happened here. Let
me show you this story first.
Cuz she So, she posted this on social media, and she said, "I
just got my
done by Shontel."
>> Okay. Now, I didn't want to know that.
I don't want to know what your dis >> Yeah, that's probably
why you didn't follow her on Instagram. The reason you know about
it is cuz you follow their snark subreddit, right? And you have
for a long time. Dude, it's so funny hearing all of his complaints
about snark now when he has he was like the number one snarker.
Every single person who was ever against him, he followed their
snark subreddit immediately.
And then he did his whole song and dance about snark. It's so
embarrassing, man.
>> nasty businesses about lasering your And by the way,
I saw her later say this wasn't even a sponsored post. She just
said this cuz she said this She's a
She wasn't even paid.
>> She runs an OnlyFans page. That's like her primary income.
That's she's probably advertising.
If If you're any amount intelligent,
you could think, "Oh, well, probably a lot of people following
her on Instagram follow her on OnlyFans. Maybe they would sub
to see
what that job How well it How good a job Chantel did?
I'm just saying. >> I don't think it makes her a pervert
to post it, but it is gross. >> I mean What would they
say about me if it was like, "Hey guys, I just got my butt hole
>> He like doesn't understand it. Dude, these people they're
so bad at this. >> I'm telling you for no reason. It doesn't
benefit me at all. So, I saw
you know me, I'm always working.
Always got my ear to the to the tracks.
>> When it comes to hating on these two >> Listen,
and people go, "Oh, it's so >> You're not always working.
I'll tell you >> Are they going to post that or are they
going to talk about how it was from their snark subreddit?
Surely they're going to include that detail, right? They're not
going to try to avoid the fact that he was browsing someone else's
snark sub. Right? But >> Yeah, but people go, "Oh, he's
so
Bro, what are you talking about? I literally told you from the
get when this whole thing started that I would never leave them
alone. That I would obsessively follow I will never When everybody's
forgot >> That's so based, Ethan. We love that for you.
I literally couldn't care less about your obsession. What everybody
cares about is your your absolutely hypocritical made obsession
with Anisa while claiming that your snark subreddit is trying
to you, you
Nobody cares about the fact that you look at snark, that you
don't like Anisa, that you want to talk about iDubbbz and Anisa.
Nobody cares. It's your It's your absolutely moronic double standard
where you think other people shouldn't be allowed to snark you,
where you want your snark snark subreddit banned, and you constantly
complain.
You are a cry bully. You do all of the things you actually whine
about. That's why nobody takes you seriously. That's why you're
a [__] That's why you don't have a spine. That's
why you keep suing people. You can't take criticism ever. >> forgotten
about them and gotten over all
I will never stop.
And so they're like, "Oh, I can't believe he's sending her nasty
laser
updates to it to the group chat to and saying ew." It was saying
how nasty it is. Oh, I can't believe it. Why?
I told you I was going to be doing this.
Tell Anissa to don't post Tell Anissa to don't post her updates
on the timeline.
>> Dude, he's not even doing good delivery. Like why don't
you tell Anissa not post her post her updates on the god damn
timeline. Why couldn't you put emphasis in there
Like it's just so awkwardly delivered. >> I told you I
was going to be doing this.
>> Tell Anissa to don't post Tell Anissa to don't post
>> Tell Anissa to don't post. Tell Anissa don't post all
her updates on the
updates on the timeline.
Why did you do that? >> I know you're watching. >> so
painless. I'm sad I waited so long. I wish I laser my sooner.
>> I don't know.
>> Like I don't need to know that her vag is like I don't
want to know. It's disgusting. She repulses me. >> I think
vaginas are disgusting.
If she repulses you, why do you keep looking at everywhere that
follows her? Why are you obsessively You just said you were obsessed.
You're going to remain obsessed.
Why would you remain obsessed with somebody who repulses you?
>> Okay, 16,000 points.
So people really got a kick out of this.
And you can imagine the dumbest loser snarker idiots were like,
"He's a pervert. He's obsessed with her. He He >> You literally
said already in this stream that you were obsessed with her.
You literally said that 2 seconds ago, Ethan, do you remember
what you said like 3 minutes ago? Ethan, do you understand what
you said, like 3 minutes ago? Did Did you follow it at all? Eventually
avoids the one 12K
from Fomoy. Wow. Fomoy. Fomoy.
>> All right.
He's downloading to put in his spank bank. You can audibly hear
me go
>> That's just facts. That's just facts. You didn't copy
paste to put it in some a chat. You didn't copy paste to put
it somewhere. You just saved. You just saved it for later.
>> when I pull it up. And then in group chat it's with
puke emojis. She is revolting.
And by the way, if you're like, "Uh, these guys are talking about
my
>> Thin line between love and hate, man. >> It's
like, then don't post it.
Don't post it to the timeline. And then act horrified when people
talk about it. >> Surely he's going to point out the fact
that while at a poker game, while at a poker table, at a public
event, Ethan Klein is such an antisocial weirdo that he pulled
up a snark subreddit, was scrolling snark subreddits, or follows
them and was scrolling Reddit in general at a poker table, and
then stopped on a snark subreddit to screenshot an Anisa thing
from a snark subreddit.
That's how in Ethan's head Anisa is, that while he's doing while
he's out, he's social, he's hanging out with people, he's playing
poker. He loves
He's that obsessed that he's going to jump back into Reddit,
start scrolling, and then save snark posts on these people. Which
by the way, saving saving snark posts not a problem unless you
complain about it, say it's like trying to get you killed. Then
you look like a
>> idiot, dumb ass, Edmonton. >> Oh, I would say
basically objectively though, you are you look weird as [__]
Right? Being at this event, being out in public, being at a filmed
televised
and pulling up Reddit on your your to save snark posts about
the people you hate, the people you're obsessed with?
hundreds hundreds of thousands of dollars on the line and browsing
Reddit.
that's Ethan Klein for you.
>> Come on.
>> Broke, repulsive.
>> Look how they do me. Look how they do me. You can see
my whole ass which I just got lasered.
I mean, we're ready for either baby number one. I do hope they
Got you well. What's going?
Congratulations to the Eklers for expecting baby number one.
Got both names ready.
>> So, that's the Reddit app. That is the snark subreddit.
That's the What is it? I miss the old iDubs.
>> By the way,
I do believe and some people have said, "No, that's not what's
happening there." I do believe that's what's happening precisely,
isn't it? He's got it pulled up. He's got it pulled up. And then
he goes back out of the full screen and then what he's doing
is he's cutting the name of the subreddit out of the screenshot.
So, when he was sending that to his coworkers, he didn't want
them to know that he got the screenshot from the snark subreddit.
That's what he didn't want them to know. Now, I would ask those
coworkers, if those coworkers care to answer this, when he posted
it, did he say something like, "Oh, um um um well, somebody sent
me this. Isn't it crazy?" Cuz he seems like the kind of guy who
try to distance, who try to make it seem like he's not someone
who goes on these snark subreddits and is just an objective snarker,
right? >> I'd put my you know, meat grinder then jack off
to that. Sorry. I know that that's what they think I was doing,
but I wasn't. Ethan got caught
zooming in on a picture of Anisa
and taking a screenshot
in the middle of a [__] diner, [__] He
is just medically unwell. >> HE'S LEARNED WELL FROM MR.
DIIORIO, hasn't he? With the tone indicators, he's learned very
well. Immediately goes to tone indicators.
Very cool. Very, very cool. >> about her just supposed
to do her time when she laser her nasty I don't want to know
that. Did not want to know that.
Was noteworthy.
It's extremely noteworthy.
>> I didn't want to know that. So, I saved a reminder of
it. I DIDN'T WANT TO KNOW THAT. IT WAS REALLY GROSS. SO, I SAVED
MYSELF A reminder so I could bring it up later and talk about
it again and again and again.
He's like making love to his wife. He's like, "Remember how gross
it was that Anissa posted about her uh her hairless
>> Um also I don't know if it's I don't know if it's medically
unwell. It's unwell. I am unwell. I'll admit that. I mean, yeah.
Yeah, you're pretty medically unwell, Yeah, I guess this episode
is bringing your brains out. Okay, but but they're referring
to to to me being a hater, Is that I I Listen, is it medically
unwell? I don't even think that really that matters, frankly.
Okay? And and
Turned out spoke at tournament. Who Who can you spoke brows at
a poker
Well, listen, they're like experts on poker etiquette.
She said, "I wrote that. I regret checking the internet before
going to bed. I regret checking the internet before playing poker
to learn about your nasty laser
Keep that to yourself, freak.
It wasn't even like Again, it wasn't even sponsored. She just
wanted to let us know >> Okay, dude, she shouted out a
small business. What a terrible person. Oh my god, imagine shouting
at a small business to somebody with a big following. Oh my god,
what a disgusting human being. What a What a shh Shouting at
that small business that provided her a service. So what? So
gross. Yeah, you're so right, Ethan. Thank you. >> Nasty,
bro. Casey Tron, of course, feeling real comfortable with herself
um after taking the fattest L, groveling for forgiveness. That
girl better be >> K- Casey Tron, thank god for Casey Tron
who let herself get Casey Tron's kind of like a Christ-like figure
in some ways. Not actually, that's a meme. Uh but she is like
she sacrificed herself for everybody else, okay? She got totally
She got annihilated so badly that it gave it let us all see Ethan's
hubris so clearly, all right? Where he's telling her you have
to apologize to Asmongold now, actually.
You You lost this lawsuit over copyright so bad, I'm going to
make you apologize for saying Asmongold got his mom killed.
>> The [__] she's she's a little too close
to the sun. >> very rude, very rude. >> sign a non-disparagement,
right? Only through the grace of God cuz I have the
I don't need the grace of God. I am the grace of God as far as
Casey Tron is
Right? She said. HasanAbi course DM. The HasanAbi industrial
complex is going to work, boys. Ethan Klein got caught zooming
in and screenshotting a picture of Anisa Jomha from the iDubbz
snark Reddit.
He previously claimed he was against snark pages. Now, listen
to this.
I don't promote snark pages on the show and we go actively out
of our way to edit it out. Ian's like, "Shoutout to snark. They're
my best mates. I love them. I don't promote snark, okay?" It
was on my Reddit feed. Reddit pushed that hard to everyone. You
>> Oh,
I don't browse. Oh, come on, man. Are you serious?
Are you
this is why he should watch the Kilo video cuz he looks so
bad in the Kilo video itself.
You see multiple examples him pulling up his browser. It's got
like the Trisha land. That's Trisha Paytas' snark
He objectively uses snark subreddits all the time. Will anybody
here call him out for this? This objective lie, this obvious
and objective lie that this degenerate loser is engaging in.
Anyone? Anyone on that that podcast? Anyone want to do it? >> problem,
talk to Reddit. That's my What I'm trying to do. Okay? Sorry,
Reddit put a picture of Anisa to announce me that Anisa later.
I want to know that. >> Dude, what the >> Picture
of Anisa to announce me that Anisa later.
I want to know that. Stop Stop yelling.
what the is going on here? >> needs to announce me that
needs to laser a [__]
I want you to know that. >> Stop yelling. Dude, this guy
is this guy is falling apart, man. Holy
>> I know I know I muted myself when I said that. I said
thank you, Dan. I need to hear that. Talk me down.
Um so Casey turned to >> Thank you, Dan. That's dude, this
is not real life. This is like actually off-putting to watch.
This is like very very off-putting to watch, dude.
>> I think that as quote influencers, we all get a bit
caught up. This is so mentally unwell. Girl, you want to talk
about mentally unwell? You smoked like 70 times during the like
You're literally a drug addict on
He's so in his own echo chamber. He won't even acknowledge how
unhealthy it is. Also creepy as He's been creepy as to this woman
for over a year. Now leave her alone. Ma'am, she told me she
lasered her My tool comes up to you and goes, "I just want to
let you know for no particular reason, I finally lasered my And
I'm like, "Weird and gross." Ew, why are you harassing her?
Sure, but but sure. You know, I'm creepy, not her. I don't want
to [__] that [__] Nobody did. Nobody
did. Who am I Who in audience was like, "Oh, sick." I'm so glad
I have that information now. I'm so happy I feel so much better
knowing this now. Carolyn Kwan, who is a a lefty Twitch streamer,
>> um the girlfriend of uh Hassan's buddy Will, who by
the way what a nice guy, no problem with him.
But she really um is very disturbed by this revelation. >> 3
minutes, God. >> Can we I didn't know it was live. I was
watching for a minute. I can't listen to these people anymore.
Just watch it for a sec just to see how serious she takes it.
She starts going, "I feel bad for his kids." I'm like, "Shut
the [__] up." >> The stans will still find
a way to defend it. You're wrong. >> You're wrong. >> It's
indefensible. If this is what he does when he's on camera, you
know, you can imagine what he does obsession when he's off camera.
The same I do the same thing. I'm scrolling Reddit and I screenshot
it and send it in group chat. >> I if if if Will I Also,
the circum This this uh beef that he has with Anisa is so absurd.
But if Will had some >> Who started it, Garand? Who started
the beef? I didn't. I was really being really nice and minding
my own business. >> Some woman. >> Well, for the
most part, I probably would have >> I can't handle these
people. >> First of all, I'd be like, "Goodbye." >> She
would leave. >> He That's classic Ethan Klein.
That's why we call him a cry bully. It's classic Ethan Klein
right there. "Oh, I didn't do anything, guys. I don't do anything.
The people just come after me out of nowhere. I didn't even do
anything. And they just come after me." >> beef her boyfriend
of several years if he was caught. >> With some woman,
okay. First of all, I'd be like, "Goodbye."
>> What's your problem here? What's going on? What's Second
of all, if you were on camera zooming in on on someone who's
who's clearly been >> No, by the way, I'm not zooming on
her cleavage, right? I'm I didn't zoom, I was cropping it, to
be clear. Dumbass.
>> I'd be like, "You are unwell, and I I would not I don't
want to be with you." >> This is really creepy. You heard
that, Ela? It's time for a divorce.
It's really gross. I don't care that you don't like this woman.
>> Meanwhile, you need to get >> Meanwhile, that
screenshot got sent to >> Yeah, it was a group chat. I
mean, earlier, I mean, we >> Ethan sending every picture
he finds on the internet of Anisa to this group chat, and his
wife's just like, "Really,
When's the last time you looked at my Instagram, bro? Come on.
Come on. Come on. Come on."
>> Yeah, by the way, we fished it up, the screenshot. I'm
sending it in the group chat. Immediately sent it in the group
chat. For for work. Says, "I'm going to talk about this on Monday."
>> [__] life. Yeah, especially when you're
married with kids. Like, "What the [__] are you doing?"
I am very familiar with misogynists
calling me calling me all sorts of
>> Who is this? >> all sorts of >> Literally
nobody. >> No, she's not nobody. She's a she's a >> She's
a hater. >> She's a leftist streamer. She's somewhat
>> Need some context here. Who the [__] are
we looking at? What What is happening? >> popular, and
she's like the size of Danum's, and she's Will's >> The size
of Danum's? >> Like, in terms of like audience. And then,
I don't know who the [__] you thought I was talking
about. And then, she's Will's girlfriend who co-hosts the show
with Hasan.
>> What they, you know >> So, like, you just webbed
this woman in. Although, she is what she is in. The way he explained
that was not great. She is like in. She doesn't like him, >> What
they view as like the most humiliating, degrading words that
you can call a woman.
>> And they think it's a way to
end me and to >> I don't Okay, now she's like, and yeah,
anyway, I'm the victim. Well, actually, I cut the part Okay,
this stupid is calling me a misogynist. Close, close, move on.
Stupid is calling me a misogynist. Move on. >> my favorite
part. I'll go to the end there before you before you before you
freak out on me. I'm going to go to the end where she gets way
too [__] >> figure it is. Behaving
>> No, just I need No, hold on. Wait. Go back. Skip past
her calling me a misogynist, actually. I need one more >> like
this online. And
it's really it's vile and their friends see it. Yeah, their friends
see this kind of stuff. I can't remember, but essentially, when
you're when you are a person who's a public figure >> Okay,
shut up. Anyway, I'll read the quote. It says, I just feel bad
for the When you're a public figure, you have kids. Guess what?
Those kids are on the They will be. Not only are they probably
learning these behaviors at home, they're also seeing their parents
or parent behaving like this at home. >> Behaving like
what?
>> Being a awesome, funny, hilarious dude with a cool job.
Role model. >> Yeah, uh Dan was just very kind here, right?
When you think about it. Let's just Let's just move on, man.
Hey, this is really long. I don't want to watch this. And
Carolyn basically says some of the stuff that they're saying
to each other behind Def Noodles' back. Like, uh this is starting
to get like weird. It's actually starting to get really weird
for us. Dude, the coughing fit, by the
The coughing fit is just crazy. That clip is going to go so hard,
man.
Him like falling back in the chair, coughing, just like spitting
rage out over and over again.
That's going to go crazy on on Twitter, on Instagram, on everything.
That's going to go nuts.
>> I respect women, Carolyn. I don't know if you know that
about me.
I respect the [__] out of women.
>> And you know what? I'm going to respect you and say
hot
>> Eric, the number one woman respecter.
>> I truly am. >> But it's just like imperfect like
leftist on I'll call them Twitter leftist to not insult the progressives
among us who are normal. Um who are immediately like, "It's the
kids. The kids like You know CPS came to my house probably, right?
Because of this nonsense.
Okay, anyway. Um also in final
It's been It's been 2 years now, hasn't it? Has it not been Is
it 2 years or only 1 year? Maybe it's only 1 year. Oh, is it
2025? The year's going slow. It's been more than a year since
CPS came to your house. You can't keep freaking out about it.
I'm sorry. I'm
It's It's stopped excusing your behavior a long time ago. >> Finally,
and in in Anisa news, this is fantastic, you guys. Ian has issued
an
for implying making the silly silly joke that I my children.
By the way, Carolyn Quan, do you have a problem
that your bestie Anisa
says I'm my children, you degenerate loser? >> It's the
the Destiny thing about Ethan and his kids. >> Wow, yeah.
That's >> That was one of those where I was like, "Oh,
man. I think I I stepped too far out with this one." Where it's
like, "I'm I We know the reason that I, you know, showed you
guys the the comments about Ethan and his kids." Because it's
like Destiny's a He's a piece of and he's clearly he has bad
intentions. But he's going easy on this guy. Not going on Not
going easy on Denims Frogan, Casey Tron, Noah. >> By the
way, they're they're they're >> Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, why is why is Ethan so kind to Destiny who says these things
about him, but so mean to all those other people? >> He says,
"What the hell is he even talking about?" >> It doesn't
make sense. Their thesis is that I'm a misogynist and I pick
on women. I probably should No, the thesis is you you have a
friend who's friends with that piece of so you don't go after
him even though he said far worse Far more objectionable things,
far more disprovable things, and he's done so with intentional
malice, right? Obvious
That's the claim. You can't just pretend you don't understand
the claim and say something else and then go, "Oh, they're saying
I'm a misogynist." I'm not saying that. >> [__]
on you more than anybody of all of them. And I'm suing Noah Samson,
by the way, as well. So, like Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Wait,
he's suing Noah Samson?
What is he suing Noah Samson for?
Does anyone know what he's suing? Wait, what is he suing Noah
Samson for? I
It's for denigration?
OH, NO, IT'S IT'S DEFAMATION. He's suing him for defamation.
Okay. Oh.
is that possible?
I don't know if that's possible. >> platformed it because
you're a cowardly loser, right? And you thought it was
to platform this horrific, disgusting uh thing. I mean, that
that honestly I would I don't I would never say that about Like
that's just that's something like, "Okay, bro." You've clearly
lost it. >> Everybody said it at the time. Everybody talked
about it. All of a sudden now he's got to change his heart. Okay.
>> Many others, right? >> And that that was my reason
for showing it. But I was like, you know, after reflecting a
little bit more, I'm like, "Ugh." I do not want to roll around
in this pig [__] It's not within my
>> to put that online. I don't want to spread that because
it's just it's just negative and >> I like, "What about
when you did your video and you're like, I think it's good CPS
went to his house?"
>> It's not true. I don't believe it. It didn't feel right.
So, that's why I'm like, you know, trying to take a step back
from the Scorch Lagoo stuff and not roll around in the pig [__]
So, >> I'm sorry. I'm sorry to Ethan and Ethan's family
for >> choking on the ash the Scorch Lagoo. You could He
doesn't want to say it so bad.
So sorry, Ethan.
>> This guy is This guy is not okay. This guy is actually
absolutely not okay whatsoever. Oh, >> the Scorch Lagoo.
You could He doesn't want to say it so bad. The So sorry, Ethan.
>> The So sorry, >> to Ethan and Ethan's family for
uh putting that nasty Destiny comment out there. Thought felt
like was an okay thing to do based on the point I was making
but yeah you're like literally grovel okay don't ask gross shouldn't
be spread like that. This is this is who Ethan is right. He always
he sees himself as like better than other people. He wants people
kneeling before him.
That's why him and Dan get along so well is they both have this
same like attitude this weird like I'm like I'm better than you.
You should kneel before me attitude. It's why they get on so
well. It's very off-putting. What are we
It's hard man. You [__] spread it for like months
bro with your watermark on your whole episode like you I mean
you know it's hard because they catch it all the time and it's
like how do I engage? Well, I have to have to while these guys
talk all the time. Gee me the content cop guy. I don't know how
to do that. I'm going to say he his children.
Epic epic bro. Because I'm afraid of her. I'm afraid of her nasty
laser beam. OH, I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY. WAS HE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THIS? Don't make me bring up nothing in a modern
You're like so let me tell you a little story. The second I had
have stopped talking about us having to coincide
when I
took into my
some fine Canadian lawyers.
That's right.
You hired oh the time I was I stopped getting criticized by other
people for being such a whiny litigious was when I engaged some
Canadian
Yeah, okay.
Lawyers that specialize in defamation and by the way, I really
don't think that's okay thing to put out. Some fine Canadian
defamation lawyers that sent a letter to
and Ian demanding
a retraction and a
of of the defamatory statements that I'm It's so it's so cool
how this guy just sues everybody who criticizes him. That's so
cool and awesome and and radical. They're hurting bad.
Look at him. Fallen off so hard. It's crazy how hard he's falling
off. It was literally the day he stopped talking about it, right?
He doesn't talk about the snark anymore. He doesn't talk about
me anymore. And Derek, by the way, desperately This this is the
ultimate irony, and I love this. America, love America.
If he lived in California, I wouldn't bother threatening to sue
him because of in our great state, we have anti-slap laws that
make it extraordinarily difficult to sue
public figures for defamation. And we have this extreme appreciation
for for free speech in the first amendment. Now, let me tell
you something. Ian, he hates America. He wants to get as far
away as >> You have a appreciation for free speech,
You have an appreci- appreciation for free speech.
>> But let me tell you something about
The north, defamation laws ain't quite the same up there.
And when I spoke to an attorney about it and showed it to him,
they're like, "Yeah, no, this this is quite bad.
This is definitely actionable here in Canada. In America,
in California,
you could say that.
Could have said that.
But in Canada, >> Why do you think we do our show here?
Exactly. You think I could do this show in Edmonton?
I'd be ruined.
>> Um do you know anything about defamation in Canada?
I can't imagine saying X person said Y isn't that crazy. Counts
as you defaming somebody. Okay, so I think defamation laws are
more restrictive in Canada. I think implications can get you
in in defamation law in Canada pretty obviously. Like there's
less of a there's no intentional malice standard either, I don't
think. I believe Canada does not have the like actual malice
standard. There there might be intentional malice. Actual malice,
like I'm doing this to [__] with you. I don't think
that's an a defense against defamation in Canada. Like you have
to do some kind of due diligence in Canada and I think Idubbbz
probably he could be like it's at least questionable cuz he's
he is going like oh I don't know about in the clip he's going
like I don't know about this. >> Land of the free and the
home >> But now that you're in Canada
I found me a Canadian lawyer who's pretty gung-ho about suing
you.
>> That's America. >> And I might just do that.
And you know he's groveling >> Wait but he's he's apologized.
>> Yeah but the damage is done. >> So this apology
>> Dude I Is Is this not just the time for Keemstar to
flip? Might it be the time for Dan to flip? He just came out
and apologized man. You're like still going to try to destroy
this guy? He just came out and apologized man. He just He just
apologized for the [__] >> apology was not
because I see people
They're taking this to mean that you threatened them and that
in response he's apologizing. No, he's just doing
>> desperate to prevent litigation.
>> Got you. >> And they've preemptively apologized
out of pure
patheticness. But you know in my opinion because we there's no
You just want to go I'm so sorry.
I think I'm going to do it right because the damages right to
my reputation
are
are terrible. I feel terribly damaged.
Um and there's actually such a crazy funny thing about the Canadian
thing too cuz he moved to Canada. I learned you can't even crowd
fund >> Woah woah. >> in Canada for lawsuits.
And you can't you
>> So I I'm not sure the exact law but if he did crowd
fund they'd have to basically ID
and verify the identity of every single person that gives money.
>> Oh, okay. >> So it's like basically virtually
impossible it would be too, you know, do something like that
on GoFundMe.
So he they're not even capable of crowdfunding for this. The
fact that he they moved the camera >> Why would they have
to do that? iDubbbz is a really successful YouTuber. >> You're
right. >> got a lot of money, right? >> Just saying.
>> No, you're you're right. I I assume a lot of people
would want to support them. That's all. >> In fact, I didn't
I hear that uh
that they never have to work another day in their life? >> Anisa
said that yeah, recently. >> Let's give it up >> Sounds
like they're pretty well
>> True, right.
>> Is he trying to go off about the being poor and Dan's
just pushing back here being like, you're kind of just being
weird? Like the whole time. You're kind of just being weird.
You're kind of just hey, you you're like kind of just being weird.
You're just hold on. Are you just you're just being weird? >> He's
probably got a lot of money, right? >> Just saying. >> No,
you're you're right. I I assume a lot of people would want to
support them. That's all. >> In fact, I didn't I hear that
uh
that they never have to work another day in their life? >> Anisa
said that yeah, recently. >> Let's give it up >> Sounds
like they're pretty well
>> True, right. >> I missed what Ethan was saying.
It's my
um should be
>> Dan is poking fun at them being poor. Oh, I see. Now
I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. >> should be no
problem for them.
But um at a at any rate uh this is about
Look, this is about protecting my family and my reputation, you
know. >> Dude, stop the cap. That's crazy.
How does he say like this? This is about protecting my family,
man. That I'm just going to keep talking about my family. I'm
going to keep exposing them to this. I'm going to keep fighting
with whoever I can for as long as I can, however I can, because
I care about my family. No, you don't.
You're opening yourself up to far worse things happening in the
future. Like you are becoming the most one of the most hated
reviled figures on the entirety of the internet. For your family?
How? How is this going to help any of them? It's totally insane,
man.
It's a just a completely insane thing to try to suggest that
you're doing this for your family at all. >> And the fact
that he moved to Canada was was a five >> is waste of skin
suing somebody again. Yes, he is. He's he's bragging about trying
to sue iDubbz right now. >> Indeed chess play.
uh against himself.
>> Very good. So, I'm very happy he moved to Canada. I'm
glad to know that we have the best and brightest protecting us
in the north.
Winter's coming.
>> I'm a woke dragon.
>> And I wish you guys the best.
I really do. I really really do. >> All right. So, why
you know
I didn't follow all this. What what what's the deal with this
Destiny
>> Thank you, Dan. Thank you, Dan. Thank you for bringing
that up. Thank you, Dan. Thank you.
>> The quote was a Destiny quote. >> But the thing
is Destiny made it clear he didn't believe it. He was just doing
it to be an [__]
Wait, we understand
that that makes it intentional malice, right? That he said it
intentionally to harm you. That's like the bar. That's the literal
bar for defamation in America. Admission of actual malice. You
You half-wits.
Is this guy serious? This guy goes, "Well, I don't want to sue
Destiny cuz he admitted it was it was uh not true. He admitted
it was not true." >> made it clear he didn't believe it.
He was just doing it to be an [__]
>> Bro, this guy is so
Oh my god. Ozempic ain't doing nothing to thin out the skull,
bro. Put a helmet on. This guy This guy goes swimming with water
wings. This guy's got some problems. I don't I don't get it.
I don't Why would you say that? How do you not know that? How
do you not have a lawyer who tells you what to say here?
>> Got it.
who knows >> that banner that was just like a >> just
a quote
with zero context
that says um um Ethan Klein versus children. >> And he
and then iDubbz put that as a watermark for his whole episode
and he's like, "Man, this is a really serious accusation. He
should really address
>> And so
I'm down to clown. >> That is That is some 40 chests for
sure. >> Yeah, and I'm down to clown and be >> So,
I thought the reason that he didn't want to sue other people
was because of how hard it is to sue somebody in America for
defamation.
What he failed to address is and now he accidentally reveals
later on is that Destiny stated he had actual malice. Oh, I don't
believe this. I'm just saying it. I don't even think it. I'm
just saying it to hurt him.
>> talk and roll around in the picture. But everybody not
just myself, everybody when they saw >> that was like,
"Dude, you've
lost your mind. This is too far. You've gone You've gotten snark
brained."
>> Now, iDubbz wasn't making the claim. iDubbz was saying,
"Hey, this is here." Now, that in Canada maybe that gets you,
okay? But in America, I don't I don't think you'd get got for
that just like quoting somebody. Maybe with the language he used,
maybe. But apparently, iDubbz a
I Listen, I'm full trust on Dickers here for a second cuz Dickers
tweeted this and I got a notification for it while we're streaming,
okay? iDubbz says in the original stream that he does not agree
with what is being said and that it's [__] up. Anyone
calling this anything less than a egregious abuse of the legal
system to chill speech is out of their mind. >> It's Okay,
so I do want to say I don't agree with what's being said in this
um comment here.
Uh but I I'm putting it on screen because I think it should be
addressed
>> So, he doesn't even agree. He literally doesn't agree
with the comments and it's a quote. He is saying he doesn't agree
with the comment and it's a quote. So there's no way to infer
that he was going I don't know, maybe you could just say you
know, I don't know. I don't know if this is true. >> messaging
me. Do you have a comment on this? Do you have a comment on on
Ethan not responding to Destiny? It's like Why did Destiny even
say this in the first place? Wasn't it because Ethan called him
out and there was this whole beef? This whole like explosion
of [__] >> And also Destiny like don't you
guys hate Destiny? Don't you guys think he's like the most like
uncredible like >> Yeah, we think we think probably that
you're one of the few people with the resources and an actual
reason to go after him. Why don't you sue him?
You're willing to sue every little content creator all over the
place. Why don't you sue this guy? This total this total piece
of
who has said you your kids. Who said he knows that you don't
your kids, but he said it cuz he he hates you like you.
>> Right. Now all of a sudden you're parading around his
>> I mean it's obviously not in good faith that they're
they're not defending Destiny's honor here or anything. >> but
yeah, exactly.
Yeah, exactly. And that this is what I I keep trying to warn
these snark
It's not you are going to yourself because you get you get in
this snark world and you think that you can just say like that
and you can't. And you think that like these snark mods who tried
to >> Unless you're Destiny. Unless you unless you hit
this guy in the mouth, right? Unless you bully him back, then
he totally folds. He totally folds. He walks away cuz he doesn't
want to fight, right? He wants to go after people who are not
willing to fight. All of these people will fold the second somebody
hits them in the mouth metaphorically in a in a like with words
sense, right? As soon as somebody bullies them back, they just
fold and walk away. They're like the biggest losers who got bullied
in high school and now want to feel some like some thrill that
they missed out on and so they're going to try to bully people
in the internet. And okay, you can do that, I guess.
But eventually, like Ethan said earlier, accountability comes
for everybody, all >> [__] who are now lost
the the whole um battle for the subpoena and are now bricks.
Guess what? Snark brain.
It didn't have to be this way. They're like, "I'm scared for
my life." Really? Log off. "I'm scared for my life. My family
never look at me the same." Okay,
turn off your monitor and go outside. None of this happens. >> Just
no no idea of the mirror he's screaming into right now.
No idea of the mirror that he is screaming into right now. Just
the most obvious and transparent mirror posting that's ever existed.
Literally, you tried to go outside. You tried to log off. You
pulled your phone out. You're still trying to browse Anisa and
I and Ian's snark subreddit. You're still browsing the whole
time. You can't unplug. You're incapable. Everything you're saying,
massive projection,
Which like, I'm also not going to throw the first stone on, but
I'm not I'm not going "Oh my god, these guys won't log off. It's
so gross." No, come join me. Just don't sue people. Ethan Klein,
you could have been a totally normal snarker.
Just don't sue people. Just don't sue people who hit you back.
That's all.
What are we talking about, man? Don't try to dox people by by
filing false DMCAs. Don't try to do any of the [__]
you're doing, right? Just There's like rules. There's rules we
all play by. You didn't like that you were getting your ass kicked
by the rules. That's why you went outside of them. You couldn't
win with just jokes, being funny, talking [__] about
people. You keep getting mocked. You keep getting made fun of,
and it upsets you so much that you sue them. You You flipped
the game over, okay? We're all We're like little 10-year-olds
around a table playing some playing Mousetrap or Monopoly or
something. You realize you're losing. You realize you're probably
not going to win, and you upend the entire table cuz you are
a whiny who ruins everybody else's fun at a genetic level. Like
you just this is who you've always been. You will never escape
it. Everywhere in your life, I know when you were a little kid,
you ruined everybody else's fun. I know it. I know. We could
go back. We could talk to people you knew in elementary school
and middle school and high school. You ruined everybody else's
fun. You were a complete
Everybody hated you and you carried that aura into your later
life. Losing at Break it.
Losing in sports? Cheat.
Well, I actually that's probably not fair. I don't I don't think
Ethan would have played sports. But still, you know, all the
other things, yeah, total piece of [__] man. >> I
have You don't understand. I have to snark. Son,
>> Dude, he's not stopping with the mirror posting. Just
the insane mirror posting.
Guy Guy in the same stream has addressed him being out at a televised
poker event snarking on his phone.
Yeah, we know, Ethan. We know. >> I have to snark. >> We
know. We know.
>> We know.